[Musique]
bonjour élise michel et merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors qu'on sait vous avez beaucoup de
travail le matin
que pensez vous de cette décision du
maire de lyon de mettre des menus
végétariens dans les cantines scolaires
on sait que la mairie de paris
planche aussi sur la question un bonjour
à tous
il ya aujourd'hui c'est quand même une
pure caricature de supprimer la viande
des cantines c'est quand même aller à
l'encontre de la biodiversité de
l'économie locale et du maintien des
paysages qu'on entretient tous les jours
à proximité de lyon alors c'est un plat
sans viande par semaine vous avez peur
que ça fasse effet boule de neige que ça
puisse donner des idées à d'autres comme
à l'instar de la mairie de paris
notamment
oui on voit que ça va vite prendre de
l'ampleur c'est pour ça qu'on a souhaité
tout de suite réagir hier matin c'est à
bure ans c'est aberrant ces mesures de
conseil municipal à dominante écologique
qui vont totalement à l'encontre de
l'environnement c'est une hérésie
d'autant plus que les repas de la
cantine sont pour les enfants de sol
repas certainement équilibrée au moins
pour une certaine partie de la
population équilibre ayant néanmoins des
eaux du poisson dans ses menus ce qui
apporte aussi des protéines
néanmoins c'est vrai que tout le monde
n'a pas forcément les moyens d'acheter
de la viande les filières courtes
également sont privilégiés donc cette
question finalement pour vous n'est pas
une question d'écologie
non non non pas de douche lorsque j'ai
vu quand même pris une c'était leur
projet de campagne qui souhaite
appliquer très rapidement voilà et puis
le ils se couvrent derrière le procès
des sanitaires
on comprend aujourd'hui que les
municipalités on leur impose quand même
des côtés des normes sanitaires à cause
du corps id traire a cogné n là ils sont
à la 7e qui sont dures à appliquer mais
on comprend pas pourquoi une viande
froide serait
pas possible à distribuer aux enfants
situation se trouvent les agriculteurs
ça apporte une un problème
supplémentaire dans la crise actuelle
pour vous la restauration hors domicile
et quand même un grand débouché
notamment sur le steak haché sur du
bourguignon sur des rôtis voilà c'est
quand même un des très grands débouchés
donc aujourd'hui ça nous inquiète
fortement 6 et 30 mille enfants ne
mangent plus demain qu'en est il de la
situation sanitaire en général on sait
que les restaurants sont fermés
qu'en est il de votre situation en tant
qu' en tant qu elle veut justement quel
impact cette crise sanitaire a
globalement sur votre travail
alors la botte c'est quand même pas tous
les bons morceaux qui sont consommés
dans les restaurants
aujourd'hui c'est tout ce qui est fils
est faufilé les rosbifs voilà tout ce
qui est bon morceau qui va dans la
restauration
et bien aujourd'hui ne seront pas
consommés sont consommer différemment à
un prix aujourd'hui en chute libre
donc c'est ça aujourd'hui qui est
compliqué à à à écouler ses les bons
morceaux qui vont plutôt dans dans des
morceaux bas de gamme et donc le prix au
dessin aussi le ministre de
l'agriculture vous soutient le ministre
de l'intérieur aussi pas forcément la
ministre de l'ecologie on l'a vu hier le
ministre de la santé où il différent a
dit qu'il ne voyait pas d'inconvénient à
ce qu'il y ait des repas végétariens
dans l'est dans les cantines scolaires
qu'est ce que vous réclamez concrètement
aujourd'hui le retrait de cette mesure
alors le retrait de cette mesure oui et
puis on demande au ministre qui
regardent les lois si vraiment c'est
cette mairie de lyon et dans la loi
aujourd'hui on demande que
les nutritionnistes nous demande d'avoir
quatre pas sur 20 avec des produits
viandes donc avec ce système là je pense
qu'ils ne sont pas dans la
réglementation donc ça on demande que ce
soit vérifiée on voudrait qu'ils
enlèvent leurs panneaux publicitaires
dans la vie qui est scandaleuse sur
toutes ces mesures qu'ils sont en train
de prendre parce que j'accroche bien con
ce qu'est décrivez-nous ces panneaux
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que c'est que
ces panneaux alors c'est des grands
panneaux qu'ils ont mis dans la ville
pour expliquer donc leurs démarches de
consommer plus local plus bio et moins
de viande
voilà donc je pense que ça va à
l'encontre des choses parce que pas
consommer du poisson je pense que dans
le rhône et en région rhône alpes ou en
auvergne on en fait peu donc ça veut
dire que d'où vient le poisson qui
consomme en ce moment même voilà où là
la filière du poisson serait un moins
écologique que la haye la filière viande
elles sont pas moins de co logique c'est
quand même qu'elle et moi circuits
courts parce qu'on en produit très peur
nos verbe ronald et donc vous réclamer
le retrait de cette mesure les parents
d'élèves d'ailleurs ont porté plainte
parce qu'ils vous soutiennent
oui on a créé donc une on a créé une
pétition avec seulement l'avenir qui est
notre association donc on vous encourage
à aller sur le site et sur la page selon
l'avenir pour signer notre pétition pour
comporte cette pétition maire de lyon on
l'invite aussi me le maire de lyon à
venir visiter nos élevages moi je suis
éleveur de bovins en blonde d'aquitaine
à 15 km de la place bellecour
je pense qu'on peut pas faire plus court
on est des éleveurs qui nourrissent nos
animaux à l'herbe et aujourd'hui on
comprend pas cette décision
merci beaucoup alice michel et de nous
avoir apporté votre témoignage en direct
ce matin sur rtl france merci bonne
journée
bonne journée